bonjour à
tous j'espère que vous avez tous passé
de bonnes vacances pour nous elles ont
été très agréables mais elles ont
également été studieuses et je passe
tout de suite la parole à Lydia pour
l'agenda bonjour à tous Voilà la reprise
première premier point presse de l'année
donc on va commencer par
l'agenda donc le parti a été au travail
évidemment tout l'été euh et donc dès
demain nous nous reprenons toutes toutes
les réunions politiques mais également
le commex mercredi euh comme donc qui
aura lieu à 17h demain nous avons à 13h
un déjeuner avec des membres de la
Fédération française des sociétés
d'assurance mercredi un entretien avec
Pascal Montredon président de la
Confédération des buraliste aura lieu au
siège des républicains à 17h comme je
vous le disais donc la Comex et et puis
samedi dans la matinée Nicolas Sarkozi
président des républicains sera à la
fête départementale des républicains du
dou puis se rendra dans l'après-midi à
l'université d'été régionale des
républicains en Loire Atlantique où il
participera donc à l'invitation de de
Bruno ritello à cette université d'été
donc un parti qui a été comme on vous le
disait tout à l'heure très actif tout au
long de l'été euh son président Nicolas
Sarkozi a fait de nombreux déplacements
le premier à Nice avec la caravane des
jeunes qu'il a lancé des interview dans
valeur actuelle dans cor matin et puis
un déplacement sur l'agriculture dans
dans Lyonne Sébastien va peut-être nous
donner les différentes dates des
réunions alors
euh dans en cette rentrée nous allons
donc continuer sur notre lancée et comme
Nicolas Sarkozi aime le dire nous étions
déjà à fond et nous allons encore
accélérer
donc nous aurons ici au mois de
septembre deux journées de travail une
journée sur
l'immigration le 16 septembre le
mercredi 16 septembre et une journée de
travail sur la réforme du Code du
travail le mercredi 30
septembre le Bureau politique le
prochain Bureau politique aura lieu le
22 septembre et tous les 15 jours
Nicolas Sarkozi va réunir les chefs de
fil des républicains pour les élections
régionales pour faire un point très
régulièrement sur l'évolution de la
campagne dans les dans les différentes
régions nos
permanences par les les les membres de
l'équipe dirigeante reprennent elles
auront lieu tous les jours de 17h à 18h
et Lidia l'a dit il y aura le la B le
rendez-vous régional des Fédération des
républicains euh mais il y aura et c'est
un grand rendez-vous
puisque il y aura un campus national des
jeunes républicains les 12 et 13
septembre au
touqu ce rendez-vous pour les jeunes
républicains est très important puisque
il y aura l'élection du Président des
Jeunes républicains et donc il a plus de
2000 jeunes sont d'ors et déjà inscrits
à ce campus national et Nicolas
Sarkozi se rendra sur ce campus et fera
un discours pour le le 12 septembre en
fin
d'après-midi alors ce weekend ont eu
lieu les universités d'été du Parti
socialiste on a pu
assister le discours du du Premier
ministre manuel Vals a été celui d'un
contortionniste il a semblait être une
boussole sans aiguille c'est-à-dire
qu'il tourne il tourne mais il ne trouve
jamais le nord c'est un discours assez
clientéliste finalement puisque
lorsqu'il va lorsqu'il est face au G du
meddeef il dit qu'il est l'ami des
entreprises lorsqu'il est devant sa
gauche il tient un discours très à
gauche voilà donc c'est un manuel Vals
qui a perdu qui a perdu le nord qui a
qui n'a pas de cap et et on a
été finalement assez peu surpris de de
ce discours puisque nous sommes à la
veille des des régionales et qu'il
essaye de rassembler euh donner
l'illusion de rassembler alors que la
gauche est totalement divisé et n'a plus
de de colonne vertébrale son discours
sur les migrants qui étai sur un espèce
de fond de culpabilisation des Français
en en nous indiquant que nous n'étions
pas assez généreux euh pas assez
humaniste et que la France devait
accueillir tous ces migrants euh bon je
crois qu'il est dans une une espèce de
dénis de réalité euh qu' ne vit pas dans
la même France euh que celle dans
laquelle vivent les Français et qui est
pleine de tension pleine de difficultés
c'est aussi un Premier ministre qui ne
parle plus de chiffres tous les chiffres
ont disparu on donne plus les chiffres
exacts du chômage on donne pas de
chiffres sur les migrants et euh et donc
c'est c'est assez c'est assez inquiétant
d'avoir un chef de gouvernement qui soit
euh si peu précis si peu dans la réalité
si peu pragmatique alors on refuse donc
cette cette culpabilisation on refuse ce
discours qui est mensonger qui consiste
à dire qu'il faut accueillir tout le
monde la France ne peut pas accueillir
tout le monde elle n'en a pas les moyens
comme le disait d'ailleurs un ministre
socialiste et pas et pas des moindres et
ce matin il se rend il se rend à
calis donc avec Bernard casenu ça ce
déplacement donne un peu l'impression
qu'il est en train de péréniser le camp
de Calais on a l'impression aussi d'un
d'un déjà vu euh est-ce que c'est un
sangat nouveau voilà nous no nos
propositions c'est toujours elles ne
varient pas elles sont toujours
identiques il faut il faut il faut
fermer les frontières arrêter Schengen
arrêter la libre circulation et aider
ces pays à se développer et avoir une
véritable lutte contre ces réseaux de
trafiquants d'êtres humains euh et
lutter avec une coalition internationale
et des troupes au sol contre daesh et
contre tout tout toutes les
organisations terroristes que ce soit en
Afrique ou ou ou au Moyen-Orient c'est
de cette manière-là que nous serons
véritablement responsables vis-à-vis de
ces populations et véritablement
responsable vis-à-vis des Français car
c'est un discours de vérité de
responsabilité que nous leur
devons un petit mot sur également
université d'été de La
Rochelle nous avons été médusés de voir
que le Parti socialiste parti au
pouvoir nétait d'accord sur rien entre
eux La Rochelle a été véritablement un
règlement de compte à UK cororal dans
toutes les commissions ça hurlit il ils
ont montré qu'ils n'étit d'accord sur
rien à tel point qu'ils en sont arrivés
à un moment ils en sont arrivés au main
et que on a vu un premier secrétaire
qu'il a fallu
empêcher de corriger physiquement un
jeune militant
socialiste et
donc on a eu simplement manuel Vals qui
est qui a fait un un discours de de
clôture qui s'est voulu rassembleur mais
qui n'a en rien masqué toutes les
divergences qui traverse le Parti
socialiste et d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans
cette épisode assez savoureux qui était
d'ailleurs en marge de cette université
d'été de La Rochelle avec des
déclarations du ministre de l'économie
sur le temps de travail qui s'est fait
recadrer immédiatement par Manuel Vals
qui avait bien compris le danger que ça
représentait pour ces universités d'été
de La Rochelle et donc d'ailleurs cette
[Musique]
polémique était une réalité pendant
pendant toute pendant toute cette
univers cité d'été euh et manuel Vals a
montré à l'occasion de son discours de
clôture qui était un discours en zigzag
euh à Manuel Vals qui finalement a
démontré que un jour il était à la
droite du PS
euh notamment lorsqu'il s'exprimait
souvenez-vous dans un passé pas si
ancien que ça sur sur les 35 heur et qui
là devant le Parti socialiste euh a fait
demi-tour à 180°r pour aller sur la
gauche du PS donc on a constaté à cette
occasion que Manuel Vals était une
véritable girouette politique et qu'il
allait dans le sens du vent en tout cas
de celui des gens qui sont dans la salle
et puis on a vu un manuel Vals qui est
dans le mensonge permanent
euh sur le
chômage on a changé les statistiques
pour pouvoir avoir des chiffres qui
soient un peu plus présentables que la
réalité ça
fait 2 mois que les statistiques qu'on
nous présente sont sous une nouvelle
forme qui permettent de présenter un
chômage qui serait stabilisé alors que
si on utilisait si le gouvernement avait
utilisé l'ancienne méthode on aurait vu
que le chômage était continué sa
progression continue euh depuis j'allais
dire des mois mais maintenant depuis des
années sur la
délinquence Lydia vient de le dire il y
a plus de chiffre et donc ça
permet de fermer les yeux sur une
situation catastrophique sur le nombre
d'étrangers qui rentrent dans notre pays
pareil le ministère ne donne plus aucun
chiffre ce qui quand il y a plus de
chiffre on pourrait penser qu'il y a
plus de problème bien au contraire et
puis à ces univers cité d'été de La
Rochelle il y a quand même eu un grand
absent enfin on va dire que les vacances
n'étaient pas terminées François
Hollande avait disparu pendant les
vacances il avait il a continué de
disparaître pendant les universités
d'été de La Rochelle personne n'a parl
de lui il a fallu que Manuel
Vals finalement fasse un effort pour
pouvoir prononcer son nom dans son
discours de clôture et c'est à ce
moment-là que peut-être les militants
socialistes sont fin finalement souvenu
que le Président de la République était
membre du Parti socialiste et
bien nous allons voir en cette rentrée
si on voit réapparaître François
Hollande apparemment il ferait la
semaine prochaine une conférence de
presse ce sera l'occasion pour nous de
voir si il existe
encore et puis pour terminé nous
avons finalement dit à l'occasion de ces
univers unité d'té de La Rochelle au
revoir au ministre du chômage pardon au
ministre du Travail François
repsamen
puisque François Hollande étant toujours
dans la petite combinaison politique
euh après la démission annoncée de
François repsoman pour quitter le navire
gouvernemental en perdition et retourner
à Dijon et bien François Hollande a
voulu attendre que les universités d'été
de La Rochelle soient passé pour pour
nommer un nouveau ministre du Travail là
encore il craignait que la nomination
qu'il a peut-être dans l'esprit euh face
des remot
euh à l'occasion de l'université d'été
de la rouelle et vous avez vu que il
n'avait pas il n'y avait pas besoin de
cela euh pour que ces universités d'été
soit des plus houleuses mais en tout cas
euh monsieur resamen laisse finalement
deux cadeaux euh à son
successeur c'est euh je l'ai dit le
changement de mode de calcul des
statistiques du chômage qui permettent
euh de faire croire à une
embellie qui permettent finalement de
truquer les chiffres du chômage et puis
le deuxième cadeau on l'a appris pendant
l'été c'est euh la suppression euh de de
de la relance des chômeurs euh par SMS
c'est-à-dire que vous vous souvenez de
cet épisode aussi où on nous vous AZ
expliqué un mois où les chiffres étaient
catastrophiques que c'est parce qu'on
avait envoyé deux fois le SMS au
chômeurs qui avait oublié de se
réinscrire euh pour qu'il le fasse et
donc en se souvenant de cet épisode
assez douloureux pour le gouvernement et
en tout cas pour le ministre en charge
du chômage et bien
de de de de maintenant supprimer
carrément la relance qui a lieu chaque
mois euh en en espérant que un certain
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi oublieront
la réinscription ce qui pourrait avoir
un effet positif sur les chiffres donc
là aussi on est dans le mensonge
permanent
malheureusement alors grande déclaration
à La Rochelle qui a été répété et répété
de manière incessante pour pour que les
Français euh oublient euh les
augmentations d'impôts qu'ils ont dû
supporter depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
François Hollande euh comme si les
Français avaient la mémoire courte et
qu'on que finalement les socialistes
prennent un petit peu les français pour
pour des osau avec cette pirouette une
promesse de baisse d'impôt de 2
milliards d'euros alors je ne je je ne
vois pas vérritablement comment cette
promesse de baisse d'impôt de 2
milliards d'euros peut avoir lieu sans
qu'il y ait une baisse des dépenses
publique c'est surtout une promesse qui
arrive après 3 ans d'augmentation
d'impôts plus plus de 50 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts 104 impôts et
taxes depuis l'arrivée de François
Hollande et de son équipe au pouvoir et
aujourd'hui à l'approche des élections
on nous rabat les oreilles avec des
promesses de baisse d'impôts 2 milliards
en moins sans toucher le la dette
publique donc on a affaire à des à
véritable véritable magiciens on la
dépense publique ne baisse pas non plus
euh les les socialistes sont sont des
magiciens voilà à un moment où le
terrorisme la menace terroriste est
extrêmement forte où il faut renforcer
les effectifs de la police où le budget
de l'armée doit être renforcé également
où vont-ils faire les les économies dans
l'éducation je sais pas avec les des
emplois aidés qui sont créés et qui ont
un coût de de l'ordre de 500 millions
d'euros euh voilà on on a vraiment du
mal à comprendre la manière dont ils
vont réussir à faire à rendre cette
baisse d'impôt effective puisqu'ils ont
promis qu'il n'y en aurait pas non plus
pour pour pour les ménages les les plus
riches d'augmentation d'impôts euh donc
là ça relève encore une fois du du
clientélisme de de la gauche et et je
pense que les Français ne seront pas
dupes et ne seront pas oubliés ces 3
années d'augmentation d'impôts c'est un
peu comme ces magasins qui juste avant
les soldes augmentent les prix des
produits pour ensuite concéder une toute
un tout petit pourcentage de de
réduction c'est ce qui'est en train de
faire le le gouvernement en tout cas
c'est l'impression qu'il donne euh c'est
la rentrée des classes également avec
Najat VO Belkassem qui est en grande
difficulté face face aux enseignants et
avec cette réforme qui a été très très
mal accueillie par par le corps
enseignant qui annonce qui a annoncé
d'ors et déjà une une mobilisation
contre contre sa réforme est-ce que tu
peux là-dessus
sur la base d'impôt je voulais ajouter
une petite chose c'est que on a vu donc
pendant cet été que François Hollande
était rentré en campagne électorale pour
sa réélection et alors que le pays va
mal alors que les chiffres vous l'avez
vu du chômage les chiffres euh sur le
déficit puisqu'on avait appris que euh
le déficit au premer trimestre 2015
avait augmenté de 50 milliards que
contrairement comme l'a dit Lydia il y a
quelques instants à ce que le
gouvernement essaie de marteler il n'y a
pas de réduction de déficit et bien on a
eu cette annonce Tony truyante de
François Holland euh qui euh est
finalement maintenant devenu un petit
guimiic médiatique puisque à chaque fois
que un membre du gouvernement ou un
membre du Parti socialiste fait l'objet
de euh d'une interview bien n'oublie pas
de rappeler qu'il va y avoir une
diminution des impôts et bien c'est
vraiment la preuve que François Hollande
aujourd'hui est rentré dans un processus
de campagne électorale présidentielle
ces élections ont lieu dans un peu moins
de 2 ans et je pense que il y a d'autres
choses à faire à la tête de l'État
conttenu euh de la situation dans
laquelle est notre pays que de se
préoccuper de sa petite personne et de
son avenir et de savoir si en 2017 il
pourra euh à nouveau se se se
représenter et espérer l'emporter sur la
rentrée scolaire effectivement le
gouvernement est à la peine euh madame
NAT Valo Belkassem est en grande
difficulté à tel point que elle a besoin
d'une béquille pour l'aider dans cette
rentrée cette béquille s'appelle
François Hollande qui va
l'accompagner demain dans l'aine dans
une petite école rurale
euh pour essayer d'expliquer cette
réforme qui a été mise en œuvre contre à
la fois les enseignants euh les parents
d'élèves et qui s'est fait sans aucune
concertation et donc aujourd'hui et bien
on essaie de faire de la communication
euh pour essayer de de faire passer
faire croire que on a réformé que que
tout va bien que
l'éducation est maintenant dans un état
euh superbe après euh ce qu'a pu faire
la droite pendant euh euh le le
quinquena précédent alors que
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que cette
réforme personne n'en veut et que elle
est en train d'accoucher au forceps à
tel point que les enseignants et bien
sont en train de préparer une grande
mobilisation et d'ailleurs c'est aussi
en cette
rentrée un moment pour faire
euh le bilan euh final des
mécontentements puisque nous allons
avoir une rentrée sociale très agitée
pour le gouvernement parce que outre les
enseignants les agriculteurs sont
mobilisés les maires de France sont
mobilisés avec la programmation d'une
journée mairie morte et puis les
médecins
également se mobilisent en cette rentrée
donc ça va être une rentrée sociale très
forte euh avec jeis dire àite tempête
sur notre pays compte tenu de tous les
mécontentements qui ont été générés par
le
gouvernement et puis il y a eu un
événement la semaine dernière
particulièrement
euh scandaleux
euh
avec une action intolérable de la part
du
gouvernement dans notre région norpadcal
et Picardie c'est le blocage pendant
plus de 24 heures de l'autoroute à 1 par
les gens du voyage et alors que on était
dans une période de retour de vacances
importantes et bien les gens du voyage
ont envahi l'autoroute à 1 pendant 24
heures pour réclamer
que quelqu'un puisse assister aux obsèes
quelqu'un qui était incarcéré puisse
assister aux ob et on a euh été en
présence d'une absence d'une disparition
totale euh de l'autorité de l'État à
cette occasion euh monsieur casazenuf
qui euh aime avoir parfois un discours
très martial était aux abonnements
absents et euh et bien nos concitoyens
ont été confrontés à cette situation en
tout cas ceux de de de la région
npadcalpicardie mais si un certain
nombre d'étrangers qui traversaient
notre belle région pour rentrer chez eux
et bien ont été euh bloqués de manière
incompréhensible pour eux par par les
gens du voyage avec des dégradations
très importantes d'ailleurs de
l'autoroute qui fait que une fois qu'ils
sont partis il y a il a fallu encore de
nombreuses heures pour remettre la
chaussée en état impliquant un coût très
important et donc nous nous sommes
scandalisés euh de l'absence de l'État à
cette occasion si tous ceux qui ont des
récriminations à faire notamment par
rapport à la justice et bien bloquer des
portions d'autoroute de notre pays je
pense que notre pays serait
malheureusement bloqué en permanence et
donc il y a eu un vrai
problème à cette occasion problème de
principe et puis problème par rapport au
rapport aux gens du voyage et comme l'a
dit ce matin
euh Xavier Bertrand sur une radio
périphérique comme on dit euh je pense
que euh
aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de personnalités au au plus haut
rang dans dans dans notre pays et bien
ont quelques inquiétudes dans les
rapports avec les gens du voyage et donc
je crois que l'État doit faire preuve de
la même fermeté avec qui que ce soit
dans notre pays que ce soit des gens du
voyage ou que ce soit d'autres personnes
qui euh portent atteinte euh finalement
euh la liberté de déplacement de nos
concitoyens et au respect tout
simplement de la
loi ce que dit cette affaire de
l'autoroute à 1 c'est également que des
groupes constitués des minorités peuvent
faire plier euh la République euh et
peuvent mettre en place un un un
chantage à la République et à la justice
ils auraient pu attendre la décision
d'ailleurs c'est un droit commun pour
les détenus de pouvoir sortir et d'aller
se
rendre à la cérémonie voilà puisque
c'était le père du détenu qui qui devait
qui devait être il euh donc c'est une
espèce de chantage qu'on voulu mettre en
place ce groupe un chantage à la
République et à la justice et je pense
qu'il en va de la crédibilité de
l'autorité de l'État d'identifier les
personnes qui ont participé à cette
mobilisation et de les condamner c'est
un signe fort qu'on pourra qui qui sera
envoyer à toutes les personnes qui
auront l'idée d'utiliser la violence
pour faire plier la République et ses
règles